[Music]
that is an Impala or as we call it in
South Africa a springbok I shot one dead
when I was 10 years old and I hated it I
hated seeing such a beautiful wild
animal died because of me
hunting clearly wasn't for me so my
first hunt was also my last since then
Africa's majestic wildlife has become of
almost spiritual importance to me
there's something quite liberating about
looking into the eyes of an animal that
could kill you and it's humbling to see
an elephant family interact and think
that perhaps it's us who have much to
learn from them so there is no cause I
feel stronger about than conservation
and then something happened that really
up the stakes
Cecil the lion remember that a global
news storm a hunt gone wrong the wrong
line shot a famous line sessile star of
BBC documentaries the shooter an
American dentist called Walter Palmer
the reaction under both your defenses
and [ __ ] make you somebody your
taste stuff you just won't have it
I know that was ugly but welcome to the
divisive world of trophy hunting every
year thousands of foreigners go on
organized hunts in Africa they take home
with them the animal head or trophy to
hang on their wall they pay tens or even
hundreds of thousands of dollars for
these trips the costs include a fee for
the animals shot as well as professional
hunting guides trackers accommodation
and travel costs now it's easy to hate
this but what if I told you that hunting
can be good that it can help protect
Africa's wildlife preserving scenes like
this I know counterintuitive right and
today I'm not going to convince you not
to hate photos like this one if you
already do and I'm also not going to get
into debate about the ethics of killing
animals whether they be lions or
chickens emotionally I wish we didn't
need hunting but objectively right now
regulated trophy hunting is a good thing
for Africa there are three reasons why
let's start first Resources Conservation
doesn't happen by accident it's an
intentional managed process requiring
resources huge areas of land fences
water supplies managers and ecologists
and squads of armed Rangers to protect
against illegal poaching this all costs
money in a part of the world where
people are very poor it's hard to expect
people who live like this to care about
nature conservation before their basic
human needs have been met
food shelter financial security which
brings us to the second point the
biggest killer of wildlife by far
anywhere in the world is human
encroachment wild habitats are destroyed
to create farmland animals are hunted
for meat
remember in Africa many people eat
protein starve diets and cannot afford
meat
farmers in America might complain about
the occasional wolf well try being a
farmer in Africa hyenas leopards pythons
crocodiles elephants are shot because
their sample crops lions killed because
they eat livestock hippos offer danger
when they're alive we can feed a whole
village if they're dead and this problem
is only getting much bigger
Rooker's population is exploding look at
this chart like epic performance from
Africa over the next hundred years so
there has to be an economic incentive to
conserve wildlife and hunting can
provided by setting hunting quarters
below the animal population growth rate
and by targeting older male animals
hunting can be both sustainable and
profitable and that gives landowners an
incentive to convert from commercial
farming to game reserves it works since
regulated Rhino hunting was introduced
in South Africa the white rhino
population has grown tenfold the best
example is Namibia's community
Conservancy programme Namibia has gone
and given ownership and management of
wild land over to local communities
income from hunting and tourism goes
directly into conservation expenses
local communities gain income jobs meet
these conservancies now cover an area
larger than England okay so then what
about the other option for generating
income photo tourism I long for the day
when tourism can carry the weight of
sustaining Africa's wild areas but we're
a long way off from that tourism is a
large industry but it's concentrated in
a few areas it needs to be safe and
close to airports
whereas trophy hunters will go anywhere
and pay top dollar to pursue their
passion let's look again at those
Namibian conservancies they're clustered
up in the north of the country and on
this map they've been color-coded to
show which of them are currently
profitable green and which are lost
making red now let's simulate what would
happen if we remove the benefits of
hunting the map changes green to red and
those red areas they go back to what
they were 30 years ago cattle farms land
over graze to dust
so you see hunting is sustaining remote
wild places that many people have never
heard of and now now hunting can help
pay for protection against the new
crisis the rampant illegal wildlife
trade driven
I demand from China and Vietnam for
rhino horn ivory and lion burn rider
horn is now worth more than cocaine or
gold and that means these incredible
animals having their faces hacked off
sometimes while they're still alive and
this this must never be okay we have to
be better than this
unlike hunting this killing is
unregulated unsustainable and totally
out of control
and we need every conservation tool
available to prevent it now not all
hunting is good as in any system there
are problems and abuses and canned
hunting is one of those animals often
lions bred in captivity so that they can
be shot in staged tonnes these lines are
tame they can't even hunt for themselves
they're taken away from their mothers
when they're three days old so that the
mothers will breed again and again real
lions are raised by their mothers for at
least 18 months hunters need to take
responsibility for stopping this because
it's their dollars they keep it going
other hunting systems may be run with
incompetence or corruption meaning the
benefits don't flow to local people but
this means we need to seek improvement
not shut the whole thing down and right
now this is real since that's all the
line 45 airlines have bound the
transport of animal trophies and several
Western governments are considering
import bans the whole thing is under
threat and as we saw in Namibia a
knee-jerk uninformed ban could lead to
the loss of huge areas of wild land and
then what about the 184 thousand people
who live on Olivia's conservancies who's
thinking of them what about African
citizens of other countries who live
with and support trophy hunting almost
all the anti hunting backlash comes from
wealthy people it's it's so ironic it
sometimes feels like the two things that
Facebook warriors around the world care
about when it comes to Africa our human
poverty and wild animals
yet the anti-hunting campaign could hurt
both human poverty and wild animals so I
dislike hunting but the majesty of
Africa's wildlife has been one of the
highlights of my life I must do what I
can to preserve it for future
generations that means making hard and
informed choices and it may also mean
having to cooperate and coexist with
those who are different from me those
who might may never understand in
pursuit of a shared goal I hope that
this talk has helped you to see some of
the complexities of conservation and how
hunting can play a role and finally I
really hope that everyone in this room
one day has the chance to come to Africa
how's the holiday of a lifetime live to
the rhythm of nature shoot with a camera
not with a gun you will support jobs and
conservation and if enough of you do
that one day we won't need to kill to
protect thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]